i'm gonna dig into your past how you dig
into mine i
i already know a lot of stuff and uh you
know like there's a lot of surprises
coming up over here the other siblings
are gonna get a little bit exposed
[Music]
are you cool with andre exposing your
sibling i mean if you walk into it
that's on you
it's blowing your mind cause you're
crazy no i'm not
crazy
let's talk about the boat fight that
recently happened with you elizabeth and
your sister becky
i'm sure you watched that back right
right yes
okay how did you feel watching that back
it just brought back all of my
feelings of anger that i had in that
moment and
just pissed me off again and i literally
felt
so amazing like watching myself just
finally like
putting them in their place and telling
my family how i feel about how they've
been treating him for
so many years
well andre how do you feel about your
wife defending you so strong
it's about time that's what the hell it
feels like i've always defended you both
ways
always defended you but i've never got
into a physicality with my family to the
point where i'm so pissed off
words don't mean enough but i just have
to literally like touch you
well libby you mentioned that when you
feel like your family is attacking andre
you feel as if they're attacking you
can you break that down a little bit
because i don't necessarily see it that
way because andre's actions are andre's
actions you know
and sometimes they have nothing to do
with you look at the end of the day i'm
always gonna have my husband's side i'm
always going to fight for him and if i
feel like my family is disrespecting him
then
i'm gonna stand up for him and i'm gonna
speak my mind you want a loan
like a hundred grand maybe
well let's get into the money there's
been a lot of criticism when it comes to
you asking chuck for a hundred thousand
dollars
what's your response to everything that
the fans are saying right now
i don't feel bad at all because i'm
asking for 100k i'm not asking for a
just like give it to me i'm asking like
as an investment and
in fact everybody did that to chuck
everybody got uh the same treatment you
know like he's been helping
like his his sons and his daughters in
all kind of ways giving the money
you know like uh just like for starters
to charlie
they gave him to uh january like when he
started
we just don't want to share the fingers
that are selfish i'm actually the only
one he hasn't
given money to like yeah as an
investment like
he considered you before he considered
me exactly
which is kind of ironic i think one
issue was okay you're asking for a lot
of money but the other
issue is how you asked for for it
it came off a bit entitled to fans as if
chuck is obligated to give you this
money or
you haven't necessarily shown him that
you're good at the craft and you're
asking for
such a lump sum i think that people
people have a hard time with your
delivery because of where you're from
you're very abrupt and you're very
straight to the point and i feel like
some people
take that as being rude or something
when he's actually just that's just how
he talks
i don't feel untitled at all if i'm
being direct
maybe the truth and hurt sometimes and
the
reality hurts on people but what can i
do you know like it's
it is what it is you know like if you
don't like how i speak you don't
you don't listen to me but the fact is
i'm lucky enough to chuck hearing what i
have to say because i'm married to his
daughter
and his daughter needs the same
treatment as the other siblings that's
why
i ask and i want the same opportunities
as everybody else but it's not a
treatment though that's the that's what
you give them
that's the confusion it's an investment
yeah whatever they did with that
investment is up to them but
we are different yeah and we'll take it
and run with it and actually make it
into something it's not just giving
somebody money
because they want money right because
i'm not just like spending it tomorrow
right okay well libby on top of the
moldovan wedding that chuck paid for in
100k
it's easy for people to think that
you're allowing
your husband to take advantage of your
dad not at all it actually
it makes me laugh and i don't see it
that way at all because
every dad most dads traditionally in
america play for the bride's
wedding so it's not taking advantage of
him he's my dad he's paying for my
wedding and
that's okay if he wants to do that
that's up to him and again
and the 100k thing like let's not get
confused that was something that he
andrei wanted to actually ask my dad i
told him how i felt about it and i
thought maybe it was too soon
and it wasn't my idea that this was all
him
andre in the most recent episode you
didn't
admit to manipulating chuck
i said you've got money right if that's
called manipulation i guess that's what
i'm doing
right exactly if they feel that i'm
manipulating
and they feel me but this is how i act
like you can call it whatever you want
but
goal for me is to just achieve my my
target i don't care like
how how you treat my like my behavior
for me enough personally like i don't i
i just look
as selfishly as it sounds like what
for my family i wanted what is good and
various i don't care
like the truth might deliberately bad
that's not my problem yeah but at the
same time my dad's not an idiot
and he appreciates your work ethic and
who you are i think at this point you
guys have started to build that and you
understand each other more
so if he thought by any means that he
was taking
advantage of him or manipulating him i
think that he would probably be like
okay hold on a minute but he's going to
warm up to me
i know how to get around yeah andre just
stop talking about that
mastermind of the family manipulate
everyone like
right if you're smart but i don't think
you're that smart
okay andre did you ever consider finding
a job outside of the family business
considering
that you and libby's family really don't
get along you know maybe but
you know what i'm gonna use the
resources over here
it's it's kind of hard at this moment of
time it's like immigration and stuff
like this
uh but at the same time you're like
there's millions over here like
circling around and why not just to just
dip my hands in it so
you know like if it's money you talk you
know like i'm up for the fight
this is what it takes i'm just gonna
fight for it you're completely
jealous of the fact that i'm trying to
start building something
if charlie and rebecca are gonna act
like this i'm just gonna quit
well do you think your pride andre gets
in the way of
having a better relationship with
libby's family
maybe maybe maybe i'm prideful but i
don't think uh
that's a good uh that's a bad i don't
think that's a bad
uh skill not not still what is this it's
really true yeah i mean
you know like as i said before i'm up
for a fight you know like if
if somebody uh tries to mess with me i'm
gonna prove
that you're wrong and i'm gonna you know
like i'm gonna dig into your past how
you dig into mine
i i already know a lot of stuff and uh
you know like there's a lot of surprises
coming up over here and uh
oh yeah more than what we've experienced
already
oh yeah it's it's gonna it's gonna get
harsh right like it's gonna get
right now it's gonna get fiery oh and
this is you're doing andre what can you
tease give us a little bit more than
that
it's gonna come some surprises over here
and some uh investigation that i did and
what i knew
what i discovered while working with
chuck what matters the rest of the
family so it's going to become
interesting because
it's not what really everybody was
thinking about me it's actually what's
uh it's actually the reality about the
other siblings in my family like but
the other siblings are going to get a
little bit exposed it's just so much
stuff in one it almost feels like two
seasons because it's just so many things
going on
up and down like all over the place well
they stepped on my tail and i would wake
up to
you know like they're gonna get the beer
so in other words he's saying don't mess
with me
are you are you cool with andre exposing
your siblings
i mean if you walk into it that's on you
well
if you i you know like this trip they
set up the park
that pissed me off and at this point i'm
just like you guys are asking for it
right because he told them he's like you
know i'm going to teach you a reality
i told them before this is what it is
okay well let's nip this in the bud
because lately i've been seeing a lot of
fans think that the show is scripted
especially your boat
your boat fight with your sister becky
so can you clear
that up a bit for those who are
listening honestly like a part of me
almost wishes that it was scripted so i
wouldn't have to go through all of this
crap that i'm going through but no it's
definitely not
i think they're coming from a family of
like a lot of people and their fights
already
are so you know like they're so used to
those fights they're not
even thinking about this you're already
like just making it happen and they're
like oh let's square it up and
after this the second day they're like
oh let's just say you know like
kiss some makeup this is normality like
even before i came over here
this is this is like how they do it what
are you saying is my family has always
been
somewhat chaotic and we've always had
our riff rafts and we fought here and
there and
now it's gotten really real because my
husband's in the picture so i feel like
it's maybe a territorial thing for
my family and they're just always
wanting to be protective of me but
they're almost disrespecting me in a way
that i don't think that they see
so i definitely am i'm not holding back
and i'm just over it at this point
you